c'est vraiment je loue ses cheveux
l'info a vraiment je pense à acheter une
tête tu fais une pierre cros s'ils
saluent aujourd'hui je suis avec nicolas
mer iedom
c'est là qu'il faut regarder ouais ce
que je me fais avoir acheté vous dire là
j'ai envie de vous dire la barbe the
world the bomb armé et nicolas mérieux
alliance la barbe alias tu clique ici si
tu connais pas et après tu reviens à
voir la vidéo c'est vachement bien fait
au moment
souvent quand je vous explique certains
concepts des astuces ou des choses comme
ça dans les commentaires
vous trouvez ça trop compliqué ou pas
faisable et vous auriez aimé une
démonstration
je veux faire mieux qu'une démonstration
je vais apprendre quelque chose à
nicolas oui et nicolas tu vas essayer de
le faire sur moi après quelque part
devenir mentalisme aussi mais j'ai ça
c'est que ça peut faire ça c'est vrai
parce que les gens ne savent pas
forcément mais nous coller de la salle à
ben oui c'est vrai on se connaît depuis
ça m'arrivait te présenter sur scène
numéro et quand tu passais à chaque fois
j'étais bluffé et j'essaye à chaque fois
dû faire je n'ai jamais réussi je vais
t'apprendre quelque chose sur le non
verbal je vais laisser le choix entre
des maths de la mémoire du non verbal il
a choisi du non verbal
donc on va faire référence à la vidéo
que vous allez trouver dans la
description de cette vidéo là l'idée
c'est que dans quelques minutes tu vas
être capable de trouver à quel film je
pense c'est un peu mon rêve c est trois
personnes et pourrait trouver quels
films dans ces trois personnes c'est
énorme
dans un premier temps je vais faire un
message à ma famille je vais vous faire
le tour pendant toutes les vacances de
noël dans un premier temps 20 liste de
films c'est pas un film que je vais
prendre au hasard ce film qu'on va
prendre parmi une liste
oui
si je ne connaissais pas les films ça
tombait je serai pas de faire le tour
non parce qu'en fait il ya juste la
personne elle va devoir visualiser un
film je suis toujours dans le champ où
un film qu'elle connaît elle donc toi
t'es pas assujettis à ça puisque toi tu
veux juste assujettis à la tva
concernant le plan de comptes tard c'est
bien parce que tu as fait un petit clin
d'oeil à notre conversation avant les
secousses et que seraient filmés et mis
en ligne également à wil hexagram bas
c'est bien parce que j'étais très moche
ou partie du système donc tu vas me
demander de penser à l'homme ses films
dans quelques secondes tu vas jouer dans
mon rôle de mentalist et de fermer les
yeux je veux te voir te faire confiance
et fermer les yeux une fois que la
personne ait les yeux fermés donc quand
j'aurai les yeux fermés je dois rester
le plus neutre possible
et toi tu vas lire les films un parent
ok tu vas dire inception
ok c'est génial parce que c'est
exactement le tour que tu oses avec le
numéro oui c'est ce que j'essaie de
savoir c'est trop bien j'ai enfin qu'en
flandre brunson matrix et que tu allais
regrettes tu vas laisser quelques
secondes entre chaque et mon job à moi
et c'est ce que toi qui vas me le dire à
m'en informer un des spectateurs ne sont
jamais allés voir mon job à moi ça va
être de penser à ce film
quand tu vas dire le nom de mon fils ma
réaction il va surtout falloir que je le
visualise à ce moment là reviennent dès
que tu dit son nom il faut que je
m'imagine que le film un train de se
dérouler je prends une séquence dans ma
tête et je le visualise loin devant moi
ok pourquoi les yeux fermés c'est ça
être plus simple pour toi bizarrement
les mouvements oculaires quand on a les
yeux fermés se voit beaucoup plus que
les yeux ouverts si je fais juste des
tout petits mouvements comme s'alléger
tu vois pas trop les voir alors que
regard derrière les paupières je vois
même beaucoup
il essaye de faire toi même un jour de
voir un miroir et il me prend pour un
con à ce moment là et c'est pas faux
c'est tu vas le mentalisme commence à
venir
tu commences à pressentir ce que je sais
c'est incroyable j'avais fait cette
promesse de te l'espère là on part sur
douze films tranquille race il facile
votre un petit peu long sur les matières
j'ai peut-être me mettre un peu comme ça
et tu vas te mettre un peu comme ça
comme ça vous aussi vous pouvez essayer
de le faire en même temps ah oui vous
essayez de alors de le moraliser je ne
suis pas si petit que ça je me suis mis
dans le champ de la caméra
ok attend ce qu'on voit pas très bien ta
tête mais honnête c'était évident si
petit double c'est un peu dégueulasse
est pas monté cette vidéo moi même j'ai
quelqu'un va monter cette vidéo bon
allez on y va
inception brunson matrix space jam roger
rabbit
the mask doctor who
mr bottes
starbucks demain
la belle verte
star wars [ __ ] c'était chaud mac alors
déjà est-ce que je pense l'avoir non
honnêtement je suis honnête j'ai parfois
il ya un truc où il ya comme il ya eu
plus de mouvement il y en a un
alors on va on va voir si tacita bong pa
après le petit défaut que tu aurais pu
avoir et c'est sûrement quelque chose
que je vous ai mal expliquée dans la
première vidéo d'où l'importance c'est
ça c'est cool de faire c'est de bien
prendre le train entre chaque film parce
que le temps d'enclencher mois le
processus version imaginaire et de
commencer à voir des choses devant moi
et sûrement le générer des mouvements
était peut-être déjà la rive à l'autre
film quand même c'était très rapide il
faut prendre le temps que j'allais trop
vite ou ses intérêts trop vite là je
vais trop vite
en tout cas si toi tu considères que
t'as pas lu assez d'informations sais
que tu sais que tu es allé trop vite
tu vois prend toujours le un peu plus ce
temps d'après toi je pensais à laquelle
film je viens d'écrire là ouais ok donc
c'est pas le cas je pensais pas ce que
tu as beaucoup trop écrit par rapport au
titre du film au club sauf si je vais
essayer de bluffer hockey the mask est
en fait qu encore ça c'est un réflexe
que j'ai un spectacle quand j'écris
quelque chose sur atta fait exprès j'ai
toujours plein c'était un petit baveux
mais moi je suis malin parce que je
commençais à me dire non c'est pas
facile il vous plaît mais ça que je
fasse un suspense bien joué je pensais
pas forcément le lavoir non je pense
forcément
ok cool est ce que ça te dit qu'on leur
fasse ou jean choisi plusieurs et je te
dit pas combien j'en choisis papam
à temps parce que là déjà je suis
content de la retrouver ouais donc moi
j'aime bien palier par palier un mec
j'aime bien connaître des choses je suis
sûr de connard quand je fais un jeu
vidéo
je n'arrête pas d'y jouer ton je vais
pas finir sans toucher les étoiles et
tout je suis comme ça ta vie j'ai
vraiment besoin de pallier par balles et
je veux toujours tout connaître surtout
c'est le problème c'est que je me suis
mis donc après à new super mario bros 2
sur la 3ds
donc j'ai mis tout le monde voulait trop
sucrés de le passage toutes les étoiles
et puis il y avait un petit challenge en
plus avoir un million de pièces jointes
a dû le faire donc je les fais et tu
sais ce que tu as comme ça les 1 million
pièce non à un nouvel écran de démarrage
oreilles de matane leur imputant à lord
et vous qu'est-ce qu'on fait que à
tanger choisir je choisis je choisis je
choisis je choisis gens choisis deux non
seulement ouais c'est déjà pas mal
ah ouais ou trois temps tout à l'heure
tu me dis que ou trois noms mais alors
choisi les enfants combien j'en reprends
323 3 mégas les fermes les yeux ou pas
tu veux le faire les yeux ouverts en
plus normé les yeux ouverts chez que tu
veux arrêter tout ça pour dire regardez
vous avez plein de palier possible prêt
en dollars au 15 jours pour affiner de
là en vrai on va faire 3 les yeux fermés
on a dû fermer après peut-être qu'en
fait un régional au moment où tu entends
le film que tu as choisie il faut
vraiment que tu en penses que tu y
penses que tu le visualise tentative ou
montre que tu vois une séquence 1 c'est
très important pour m'aider à le trouver
comme s'il était devant moi quoi comme
s'il est comme si tu étais au cinéma en
train de manger les petits pop corn de
boire du coca de faire chier les gens
autour de toi
la précision de ses mains extérieures je
suis prêt tu es tu aussi noir et blanc
quel cinéma je suis au mk2
dans le 20e très petit partenariat avec
le cinéma le cadeau à l'est concentre
non mais là tu rigoles se concentre pas
j'ai souri et émouvant euros tu as
choisi de trois films oui on inception
brunson matrix ce psg roger rabbit
the mask doctor who mr aux bottes
starbucks
demain
la belle verte
star wars
ok c'est bon je pense je fais comme tu
es leur jeu les notes y avait un petit
côté la garde
j'avais mis mon truc mais prend ta fille
mère jeannine et doigt sur lesquels je
pensais on verra room est donc le
premier c'est matrix ouais et après je
pense à starbucks
ouais donc il est star wars d'accord
j'ai un sur trois tu as un sans faute
non x d'arbec star wars
là c'est qu'ils mentalist je suis trop
content à genève bon j'arrête plus lourd
place à la magie maintenant attention
nicolas voulzy vers l'ailleurs vite que
le magicien point com et en plus
vraiment je n'ai pas cherché à td
puisque j'ai sûrement eu des mouvements
ailleurs qui sont des sceaux normal en
fait sur quand tu as les yeux fermés qui
n'avions rien et j'ai pas cherché à
faire dieu voilà tu vois ce genre a
surtout le truc j'ai eu la même légèreté
son génial mais c'est drôle à l'état et
du premier coup les deux messes
bravo mais qu est ce que tu t'es au tous
bluffés a complètement quoi là je suis
choquée mais ça c'est mortel c'est je
crois que jean woeffray temps en temps
de crise comme ça avec avec d'autres
guest parce que vous vous auto bleue
fait et je suis sûr c'est que même les
gens vont pas y croire et on dirait
c'est ça alors essayez attentivement
jeudi trois années écoulées les deux je
me suis fait ça mais en fait je les ai
écrits avant pour pâques et d'ambiguïté
quoi tu vois que l'ol ai dit ce que si
tu me dis je te dis oui c'est ça il n'y
a pas de preuves fois la jetée de
prouver que tu avais besoin
allez voir la vidéo où je fais les
explications c'est plus propre et plus
l'on s'est plus posé il ya plein de
petites astuces en plus mais vous voyez
que c'est complètement possible
ah oui là c'est vraiment je suis choqué
mais là dans ma tête j'ai un [ __ ] de
magicien aurait donc j'ai trop content
vidéo donc vraiment fait le c'est facile
ça c'est facile fin en tout cas moi ça
ne m'a pas plu
sinon j'espère que ce sera inspirant ce
qui vous a fait nicolas et nicolas est
lui-même inspirant sur la manière de
penser et de faire des vidéos grâce à la
barbe à la chaîne de nicolas meirieu oui
et tout va et et bloque aussi ils sont
super bien été pour remercier donc allé
voir la chaîne des nicolas meirieu prôné
c'est quelques secondes je vous mets le
lien dans la description et peut-être
aussi une petite fiche par un maintenant
je mets le lien dans la description est
également le petit cercle
à qui va paraître entre nous deux c'est
bien [ __ ] comme je le fais bien fait
vous allez voir ça c'est mortel comme
d'habitude si la vidéo vous a plu vous
pouvez liker et vous abonner au rendez
vous demain à 17 heures
ça
[Musique]